hola chicos bienvenidos al juego del
amor soy su anfitriona li zhi y esto es
si estás jugando quemados hoy me
acompañan dos hermosas solteras les
gustaría presentarse hola soy nicole
tengo 21 años soy de redondo beach y un
dato curioso es que me encantan las
papas fritas con cara feliz de videla
soy jasmine tengo 18 años y soy de tokio
japón
am hornear pan de banana pero no tengo
horno lo cual es algo triste muy bien
chicos las reglas son simples ustedes
van a lanzar una pelota a la soltera con
la que quieren tener una cita y sólo hay
cuatro espacios disponibles en sus
equipos así que apunten bien a demás
chicas si se sienten atraídas por
alguien no dudan en moverse y recibir el
golpe pero si no escriben esas pelotas a
mi señal comiencen
dios mío no están viendo
ay qué vergüenza
o el disculpen
bien
bien mirado medios lo siento
esto es mucho peor de lo que pensaba
hoy no eso me pegó
está bien
muy bien puedes elegir que esta te pegue
o esquivarla
de rojo pero
el equipo de nicole está lleno
bien bien me dio muy bien yasmín tu
equipo está lleno
desafortunadamente no pueden tener una
cita con todos pero pueden tener una
cita rápida por 10 minutos y luego
volveré para que elimines a 2 comiencen
a sonar el silbato
qué hacen ustedes quiero saber un poco
sobre lo que hacen como lo que les gusta
me llamo y sabe que soy un levantador de
potencia hago sentadillas pesas y
levantamiento de peso muerto lo más
pesado posible soy un aficionado a la
comida así que levantó para comer no
como para levantar ahorra
hola cómo estás mi nombre es manga y
hago marketing en redes sociales y
también con marcas para diferentes
películas quizás trabaje con tu película
favorita quién sabe cómo te va me llamo
malik me encanta cocinar así que si
tienes un blando favorito yo lo haré
bien te podemos cocinar juntos y
disfruto mucho de cocinar sabes soy un
actor y un tec toker me encanta hacer
volteretas si te interesa eso entonces
tal vez podríamos dar vueltas hacer
algunas cosas en la playa y eso eso es
genial no haré volteretas pero te
animará gritaré
soy un estudiante de actuación
televisiva ha ido a muchos castings
también y estoy en prácticas en una
empresa de gestión de talento así que me
encantaría verlos
cantando una línea una línea de
cualquier canción
de acuerdo adelante déjame amarte
yo seré el único y darte lo que quieras
y
necesites
llévame a la luna
preciosas
[Risas]
cuando veo tu rostro
na na na na na na na na vivo la lluvia
caer y la belleza en todo cuando el sol
sale brillando
estoy tratando de recordar
este es el final de las acciones
para los ricos sabes a quienes vas a
eliminar o dios mío ustedes son
increíbles
voy a tener que
eliminar te lo siento no podemos ser dos
actores no funcionará
y tú no pasa nada
yo también felicidades chicos llegaron a
la tercera ronda
bienvenidos a la segunda ronda
caballeros jasmine este es tu equipo
comiencen ahora
hola chicos como están sólo pueden
hablarme de ustedes mi nombre es set y
ahora mismo soy estudiante de postgrado
en la uc
no es por superarte pero yo soy de la
ufm llamo maxwell estoy estudiando
computación leo tengo un horno y estás
en el campus así que puedes venir y
hacer pan de banana cómo te va me llamo
iván tengo 22 no estudio pero trabajo
para el gobierno tiempo complicado sí
me llamo jeter actualmente estudio en el
extranjero en realidad voy a la
universidad de filipinas usted escalar y
hacer ejercicio encanta como el
escalador
y si fueran un personaje de disney cuál
sería sería russel porque cuando era
niño solía parecerme a él como esa linda
carita circular no voy a mentir tire
moulin representando
representa no sé si cuenta esto pero
como la nueva guerra de las galaxias' es
hecha por disney me encantaría acerca de
los rent si soy un gran fan de adam
driver pero no me parezco en nada a él
sabes es una respuesta controversial
pero de niño nunca vi muchas películas
de disney así que no puedo decir que
tenga una favorita o un personaje
favorito sé que es una tontería pero
sabes es lo que hay que te de burbujas
les gusta de acuerdo lo siento voy a
tener una respuesta horrible otra vez
pero no bebo boba no lo disfruto nada
tienen alguna recomendación de comida o
algunos destinos de viaje has estado en
tu living
si yo el ibi no sé si es diferente aquí
pero no hemos comido conmigo es una
crema
este es el final de la ronda de citas
rápidas
jasmine sabes a quién vas a eliminar ya
sé que estoy fuera
me adelantara y lo haré muy rápido
y tú
espero que les gusten las calcomanías
gracias muy bien felicitaciones esta es
la tercera ronda nicola eligió tres
hombres de su banco a los que los dos
finalistas deben pegarles para tener un
tiempo a solas con ella pero hay una
trampa si estos hombres atrapan la
pelota son redimidos si obtienen un
tiempo a solas al sonar el silbato no me
peguen
lanza en las pelotas
tan rápido yo diría que su cuenta o la
algo
háblame un poco de tus relaciones y
relaciones pasadas pregunta sólo tuve
una relación seria pero tengo suficiente
experiencia por así decirlo
un poco de tus relaciones anteriores me
han roto gross en un prócer veces pero
no pasa nada sólo estoy tratando de
aprender se aprende década así
exactamente trato de no lo siento me
quedé sin aliento
redención
hemos conseguido
nicole encantado hola de nuevo y
cuantas relaciones pasadas de dejar de
pensar rechazarlo
hola volvería miel sí pero en cuántas
dirías que has estado
diría como 656 no hay muchos
nunca estado en una relación ha salido
con muchas personas pero soy partidaria
de conocerte a ti mismo antes de estar
en una relación me siento bien en la
parte de mi vida en la que estoy y me
siento muy bien siendo independiente
así que tienes que conocer que a ti
mismo cuentan un poco más sobre ti
cuáles son tus señales de alerta
que no sea genial señales de alerta
me encantaría hablar contigo en persona
si es posible pero si los dos no estamos
en un buen estado mental prefiero que
nos calmemos que lo resolvamos así que
soy instructor de surf y acabo de hacer
una capacitación de profesores esta
relación
de respiración
y no es lo ideal
es el final de la tercera ronda muy bien
comiencen con el silbato
debo lograrlo
hola que tal como está si estoy bien
tomé un número por segunda vez en mi
vida hay que estar conscientes del
entorno asegurarse de estar a salvo y de
los que están contigo oh sí sí eso es
algo importante es hora de irse hermano
como venga
cómo estás cómo fue tu última relación
mi última relación fue
supongo que hablaré de mí no lo sé he
vivido muchas cosas he tenido dos
relaciones y fueron tan cercanas como
estar con mis mejores amigos bien dime
qué importancia tiene tu ocupación para
ti
qué quieres hacer en el futuro obtener
mi título
fisioterapia la kinesiología es muy
importante
qué va a hacer en el futuro alistarme en
el ejército y dedicarme a la aplicación
de la ley por eso ahora estoy en las
reservas cada vez vienen más rodados
tendré que volver a filipinas porque
actualmente estoy estudiando en el
extranjero la relación a distancia
tendrá que ser una opción eventual
que buscas en una relación o alguien que
tenga
buenas metas cuáles son tus señales de
alerta señales de alerta revisar mi
celular definitivamente si creen en la
astrología
supongo que mi señal de alerta es cuando
alguien no sabe comunicarse o me deja en
visto o cuando tanto tíos cuando me
ponen los tienen los brazos o ni
siquiera hablamos basta es el punto es
mía estoy bromeando no soy positivo y
creo que terminó el tiempo este es el
final de la tercera ronda felicidades
chicos por llegar a la ronda final
nicole estás lista para eliminar a dos
personas creo que sí estamos siendo
segura sí porque te daré un premio
compartido en efectivo que podrás usar
en tu primera con un afortunado
caballero esto fue muy divertido chicos
muchas gracias a todos por estar aquí
realmente lo aprecio yo voy a escoger a
esta persona porque creo que tiene una
vibra muy muy buena así que escojo a
malik
[Aplausos]
e
muchas gracias chicos fue un placer
conocerlos
hola voy a darte un abrazo
salimos y claro adelante te sigo esta es
la ronda final felicitaciones chicos por
haber llegado hasta aquí jasmine sabes a
quién vas a eliminar hola chicos
son muy buenos y divertidos y me gustó
mucho todas las chispitas individuales
que tienen pero tendré que eliminar t
y
de acuerdo espera me gusta estar debajo
y adónde vamos
[Música]